obviously I'm very shocked to hear the
death of a bob crow and this was a guy
who really fought for his members and to
stuck up for his point of view obviously
I didn't always agree with what he had
to say but I really will say this i
think that together with other union
members Bob Crow unquestionably helped
to drive forward huge progress on London
Underground and he leaves a massive
legacy behind you were obviously fierce
adversaries if you like and many people
will know you didn't hold discussions
with him formally the whole time you've
been mayor what do you think about that
now I think he was obviously a man who
stuck up for his views who had very very
strong principles I didn't necessarily
share those those views I'm not a you
know a Marxist or or whatever by any
stretch of the imagination but what I
admired was his indefatigable defence of
what he thought of as his members views
and his members interests and what I
just say again I think in the end he and
I probably whatever our differences
shared this goal that we both wanted to
improve the tube improve the lives of
passengers on London Transport what
would his legacy be then using to the
capital I think good I was ur thoughts
very much with Bob crows family now but
I think that they can be very proud of
what he did to push forward improvements
in standards on the London Underground
that will be of benefit to passengers
for a long time to come and one thing
Bob Crow and I were completely United I
was in fighting for the london
underground fighting for a good deal for
London because he and I certainly agreed
about that it's the London tube it's the
underground that helps to drive the
whole of the UK economy